وابدا بضيفنا من بغداد ما الذي يغيره هذا
الاستهداف
في يعني رد فعل او تعامل ما يسمى بفصائل
المقاومه الاسلاميه في العراق وردها
واستهداف للقوات
الامريكيه ردا على الهجوم الاسرائيلي
بمساعده امريكيه على قطاع
غزه بالتاكيد يعني هنالك ممكن توقع ردين
على مستويين مختلفين اولا على مستوى فصائل
المقاومه العراقيه وتحديدا على مستوى
كتائب حزب الله التي اعلنت قبل اسبوع
تجميد عملياتها العسكريه باستهداف القواعد
الامريكيه في داخل العراق يتوقع جدا ان
تستانف يستانف هذا الفصيل عمليات العسكريه
في العراق وخارج العراق ولربما تحديد
اهداف جديده واستخدام اسلحه نوعيه جديده
يتوقع جدا حتى الان يعني هنالك دعوات
للتحشيد
واستئناف العمليات وايضا يتوقع ايضا ان
يكون هنالك ردود افعال حكوميه رسميه من
قبل الحكومه العراقيه
على هذه العمليه التي تعتبر عدوانا جديدا
كما عبرت عنه الحكومه العراقيه في في
مناسبات ماضيه كان اخرها الضربات
الامريكيه التي استهدفت مقرات رسميه للحشد
الشعبي في شمال الانبار على الحدود مع
سوريا يتوقع ان ان ان تتصاعد يعني اي لغه
التنديد الحكوميه ويصار الى اجراءات اخرى
شهدنا في الايام الاخيره ليله امس كان
هنالك لقاء لرئيس الوزراء العراقي السيد
محمد الشاع السوداني تحدث عن انقطاع
التواصل مع قطع التواصل مع الجانب
الامريكي بعد الضربات العسكريه الامريكيه
الاخيره هنالك نوع من التوتر هنالك نوع
من القطيعه الغير معلنه شاهدنا ادانه
عراقيه في مجلس الامن ليله امس وما سبقها
خلال الجلستين الماضيتين اعتقد نحن ذاهبون
الى تصعيد سياسي يرافقه تصعيد امني باتجاه
الوجود الامريكي وبالتالي نسال عقيد مايلز
كاجز من الولايات المتحده ما الذي حققه
هذا الهجوم يعني الى اي مدى زاد ذلك من
امن القوات الامريكيه وقرب الولايات
المتحده من احتواء التصعيد في الشرق
الاوسط
مساء الخير مساء
الخير هذه الضربه شكلت رساله مهمه اتت
رساله مهمه من البيت الابيض ومن وزاره
الدفاع الامريكيه لقاده كتائب حزب الله في
العراق وهو مؤشر بانه ليس بطاعتهم ان
يختبئوا وان يهربوا ويجب ان يتحملوا
مسؤوليه الافعال التي ادت الى مقتل جنود
امريكيين في الاردن بالاضافه الى هجمات
اخرى شنتها هذه المجموعه والتي استهدفت
القوات الامريكيه في العراق وفي سوريا ما
يمكننا ان نتوقعه الان هو من المرجح ان
نشهد ردا من كتائب حزب الله وكما اشار
الضيف الاخر هذا صحيح والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه سوف تكون على جاهزيه ردي من
جديد من خلال ضربات دقيقه تستهدف قياده
كتائب حزب الله وقدره هذه المجموعه على
تحريك الاسلحه عبر العراق الى سوريا يعني
ضيفنا من الولايات المتحده سيد الزيدي
يقول لك شاكو
ماكو ف ما الذي يمكن ان يقال لهذا الرد
بشان انه هذه الهجمات
ستتكرر
طالما ان قوات امريكيه تتعرض للخطر في في
المنطقه ليس هنالك سوى حماقات امريكيه
ومزيد من الحماقات ترتكب في العراق وفي
المنطقه نشاهد الانخراط الامريكي واستمرار
الانخراط الامريكي في دعم اله القتل
الصهيونيه في قطاع غزه
وهذه الاله الامريكيه ايضا تمارس عدوانها
الصارخ في في العراق وفي سوريا
باستهداف يعني مواطنين مواطنين عراقيين او
مواطنين سوريين وهذا هذه كلها يعني
ممارسات تم ادانتها يوم امس وقبل يوم امس
في مجلس الامن الدولي من قبل جميع الاعضاء
المشاركين في هذه الجلسه وكانت وكان واضحا
للراي العام الدولي ان الولايات المتحده
باتت معزوله وهي مدانه واصبحت منزوعه
منزوعه اخلاقيا ودوليا
وقانونيا بفعل ما تمارسه ضد شعوب المنطقه
ليس هنالك سوى والتصعيد و يعني لا
ينتظر من ممن يتم استهدافهم يعني اليوم تم
استهداف
شخصيه يعني لعب دورا بارزا في الامدادات
الانسانيه للشعب السوري قبل عام في في في
الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب الشمال السوري
هذا شخص معروف على هذا المستوى اما
الاكاذيب التي
تسوقها يسوقها الاعلام الامريكي والاداره
الامريكيه شاهدنا قبل يومين المتحدث باسم
البيت الابيض جون كيربي وهو يعتذر عن
كذبته عندما تحدث عن وجود تنسيق امريكي مع
الحكومه العراقيه في الاستهدافات والضربات
الاخيره عودتنا الاداره الامريكيه على
الحماقات وعلى مزيد من الكذب ومزيد من
الاستهتار بدماء شعوب المنطقه
و سياده هذه
الدول يعني في ما في في في الوقت الذي
تتحدث عن عدم رغبتها في توسيع بعدم توسيع
يعني نطاق الحرب في المنطقه هي تمارس هذه
الحماقات ويعتقد يعني يعني هنال يعني لا
يعتقد ان تقف هذه الفصائل مكتوفه
الايدي وهي تتلقى
الضربات ويتم استهداف قياداتها ومنتسبيها
بشكل وقح
وغادر
طيب سيد
كيجز يعني اما والوضع هكذا كيف يمكن ان
نفهم ان الولايات المتحده تريد خفض
التصعيد وتريد هدوء في المنطقه كيف ياتي
الهدوء يعني يعني يعني هنالك مثل عربي
اسمع كلامك الداك اشوف امورك استعجب يعني
نعجب كيف يمكن ان يتحقق الهدوء بمزيد من
القصف سواء في اليمن او في سوريا او في
العراق او باستمرار الحرب مع على قطاع غزه
من قبل
اسرائيل بالنسبه الى موضوع خفض التصعيد من
قبل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه دعونا
نتذكر من شن الضربه الاولى اتحدث هنا عن
هجوم من حزب الله ومن ميليشيات عراقيه
اكثر من
17 هجوم على القوات الامريكيه في القواعد
الامريكيه في العراق وال الباشمركتيرة
يت بمكان في هذا السياق ان تضع اداره
بايدن هذه الضربه في سياقها الضربه
الامريكيه هدفت الى
استهداف القائد الذي استهدف وهو مسؤول عن
العمل الاستخباري وعن تنسيق الهجمات التي
استهدفت القوات الامريكيه البيت الابيض
عبر عن عدم الرغبه بالتصعيد والقاده في
بغداد في موقف صعب حيث ان بغداد لديها
علاقات ثنائيه مع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وفي الوقت نفسه الميليشيات
الايرانيه تنتشر في ارجاء العراق كافه
اتوقع ان الحكومه في بغداد سوف تصدر بيانا
شديد اللهجه يدين هذه الهجمات وقبل زياره
السيد السوداني للبيت الابيض بعد شهر
رمضان المبارك على الارجح سوف يكون هناك
جلسه حول او حديث حول استمرار وجود القوات
الامريكيه في العراق والعلاقه بين الطرفين
السيد الزيدي فيما يتعلق بهذا الموضوع
يعني هو اشار ضيفنا من من واشنطن الى
حسابات معقده لدى الحكومه العراقيه تصل
لدرجه الحرج ما الذي يمكن ان تقوله
الحكومه العراقيه الان للحليف
الامريكي لا هو الحكومه العراقيه هي مسؤول
امام شعبها وليس امام الامريكان ويوم امس
تحدث السيد السوداني بشكل واضح ان ان جهود
حكومته نجحت ب يعني ببد بدنه بين الطرفين
بين الفصائل وبين الامريكان ما قام به
الامريكان يعني يعرض هذه الهدنه التي قامت
بها الحكومه العراقيه وشخص السيد السوداني
الى الانهيار وبالتالي الامريكان الان
يعرضون الحكومه الى احراج
اي يعني واضح امام الشعب العراقي وبالتالي
ليس متوقعا من السيد السوداني الا
الانحياز الى الدم العراقي والشعب العراقي
هو الذي يمثله والذي هو مسؤول عنه وعن
امنه وعن سيادته دستوريا بالتالي اعتقد ان
ان ان ان الاجراءات التي ستقوم بها
الحكومه
العراقيه ستوجه الى الجانب الامريكي ذكرت
لك انه يتوقع ان يكون هنالك تصعيد سياسي
من قبل الحكومه العراقيه اي شهدنا في
الايام السابقه استدعاء ل القائم بالاعمال
في السفاره
الامريكيه لا نعلم ولا نتكهن لكن اعتقد ان
هنالك خطوه اشد من هذا
الموضوع قد يقوم بها تقوم بها الحكومه
العراقيه والخارج العراقيه لان لان لانه
لم يكن لم يعد في القوس منزع امام
الحماقات والاكاذيب الامريكيه على الاراض
العراقيه شكرا جزيلا لك مازن الزيدي
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي من بغداد ونشكر
ضيفنا من واشنطن ايضا العقيد مايلز كنز
المتحدث السابق باسم قوات التحالف الدولي
في العراق وسوريا